[Music]
today we have a bunch of four nights to
cover and just why I played the
psychology behind it
and we do have the endgame class after
this but hopefully because for night the
way I play it really gets to the endgame
and we can really get some kind of
deeper in the end theme of that as well
so basically I started playing for night
when I think I always had the idea of
four nights but I played few games and I
kind of played them bad but the first
game that I played was against and I
think the first successful one that I
actually knew what was I doing and it
felt nice and everything was against
trance i optima like I did show another
game of mine against here when I was
black and that's really cool
Lopez Janish that I wanted I'd really
enjoyed that game but this one
specifically was quite successful for me
because this was like 2013-14 I was
figuring that's what I like what I don't
like in chess and in 2015 I had that
huge jump in 2016 I got my titles so
yeah that hurts here's a little door
such as history as well and I need the
other lap to get youtube because I
forgot that
sorry alright so without further ado I
am going to start here and multitask
getting my youtube up I thought I was
doing this with my phone but I forgot
there's another laptop alright so let me
show you start off on this game so this
was the game that I played the games
John SIA
this game actually didn't get into the
endgame and so I'm good I think I have
it shouldn't be that hard to find some
clues chess club and yeah so in this
game I usually play four nights with the
d4 because it's it kind of gets into
more details and Bishop b5 just feels a
little too symmetrical let's see
better
yeah yes I'll take off my necklace hold
on let me put the mic back on
so how's everyone's day going
I I'll just take it off ah if I can Oh
got it
where'd it go there we go bye-bye
necklace okay so yeah scotch sketch is
cool but I kind of prefer for nights
just in some of the specific games like
four nights is kind of my to go one if I
don't really know what's going on or
what the opponent plays anyways so
usually they take I did have a game with
Bishop before that I will show you guys
right after so ETA XT for Knight takes
bishop comes to be for take take Bishop
d3 there are some lines with d6 and
castle as well so like castle castle and
then there would be procreate or without
t6 and rocky eight so there are some
there are a lot of different lines in
scotch but d5 is the most common one and
so after castle castle I decided to
thank you everyone for your for your
support and kind words and so in this
specific game I decided to try out h3
the main line is Bishop g5 which I have
played more often and I deal with Bishop
g5 is simply to how to put it
c6 you want to just come attack this
night
if black is trying with Bishop d6 you
just bring out your roof and as soon as
black plays h6 you in turn this end game
which I will show you after because I
have way more games than this but and
there is another line with Bishop
instead of D sequel d6 going to e7 to
avoiding this takes enough and then but
black could try to develop like this but
it's just a very safe position for both
white and black yeah
and so anyways I decided to go try this
a stream and after h3 I brought out the
Queen I could have like we should g5 I
didn't really think there was that much
of difference honestly in the game and
eventually I decided to just go with
Bishop f4 because I think I wasn't sure
about my endgame skills in this specific
game and after this one I started to
gain more confidence that yeah I can
actually try to pull something up in the
endgame and I think that's the biggest
reason I didn't want to go to the
endgame one so yeah actually long-term
weaknesses what about black that was my
C pawns so you're asking if like Bishop
c3 well it is possible but then the two
bishops and open center it's going to be
very pleasant for white so just off the
top of my head white could try and just
put the bishop in this long diagonal and
just try to bring out the rooks and
White has a nice little attack going on
yeah so that's one thing the other thing
is if black were to take it these are
not very stable pawns it is always
possible for wise it's trying to place
c4 and exchange it off so it's not
like a long-term weakness yeah so here
is that so she decided to play Bishop d6
and so here I started to get a little
defensive but this move c3 was very nice
just pushing the rook away so
intermediate moves if way you can't
always just like take you take back so
it's a good idea to have this idea of it
intermediate moves and so I did have
this idea of in intermediate moves and
eventually I'm just putting my pieces in
better places I don't know if the rook
does belong on d1 but my idea was to
just double the rooks up on D so I
didn't really feel any difference which
trip to bring yeah look see one also
looks nice so Roxy one could also be
another way to play out this game but I
really wanted to just double up these
rooks as you can see and so I tried it
to cause my and some more problems with
for black with like Queen g5 and maybe
some ideas with Knight f4 93 Knight f5
is also possible and again you see like
in this specific for night everything is
very chilled everything is just really
safe and everyone is doing both sides
have decent position there is not like a
clear advantage and it's really a
positional game that you can try to mix
dynamic with it and so yeah rook t1 and
she put h6 so now I have my first
question for you guys where do you want
to put your Queen
ooh thank you everyone for bringing the
chats well I went a lot higher and to
answer one of the things that Rey Lopez
said well yeah I mean this four-night
could be potentially a good tool to use
against your higher rated opponents if
and if someone that's you know like
whatever else you play it's a busted
opening so there are little tricks I
look like a shrink
great thank you my mother is a shrink
so okay you want to try and put the
clean somewhere like maybe h4 so the
night can get to a g3 or you want to
have the Queen on f5 so I guess the
three squares that it's most popular are
these three yeah I can I see that I
didn't I played Queen in short just
because I wasn't sure what what do I
want to do with my nights just yet
I could play 93 95 I could have 94 but I
have to be careful with myself for a lot
she played rookie six I put kind of a
unorthodox move that I could have gotten
in trouble but I didn't
I played f3 I know I know I'm not
supposed to weaken my king but I didn't
my problem was if I plan on something
like 93 now there is rocky 1 and now why
black is getting way too active for
whites to be able to do anything with
same for Knight to f4 same idea just so
I kind of went with f3 because after f3
I would be protecting the square and it
would give me more possibilities to try
and bring out the night
yeah yeah I agree with I pretty much I
agree with all of you this after II was
very hard decision for me to make as
well I'm not sure if this is the move I
would play if I was playing right now
but this is a very tough position you
want to be able to like play something
like we should have a five and Bishop e5
you want to bring us your knight but if
you touch the knight and black
automatically gets an upper hand so you
kind of yeah the other problem is
weakening III that is true but also how
can black use it cuz if black plays like
d4 you have c4 worst-case scenario and
the night is never going to actually get
to e3 so even though it's creates a lot
of weaknesses it's really hard for black
to try and use it Bishop if I was the
move that I played right after so I got
my Bishop b5 and I got the nice out g5
now you are white what do you do do you
want to take some pawns do you want to
mm-hmm
make some pans
so yeah what do you want to do would
whites
careful your queen is under attack queen
g3 I think when g3 is the most logical
one I'm just trying to get you guys to
maybe look at Queen takes h6 if anyone
wants to wait why would you play Queen
g3 Queen g4
okay so we have all right so we got the
chance to look at 26 in Queens III and
so yeah all right so the thing is
cleaner sticks doesn't really work
because after take you don't really have
enough pieces to attack and even if take
now well I could simply try and open up
the position a little bit or simply did
the problem is that even if you give the
check King goes to f8 you can't give
another check so you might have this
perpetual but I think the the real
problem could be not wait 94 doesn't
work my three four there's Queen g5 r g6
doesn't work but if Knight goes to e4
does this work
Queen a4 now a little too out there
this is why it is good here so what do
you guys think do you think we need six
works thank you
yeah that's what I'm saying you can't
attack with only Queen but what's the
actual move to play after Queen age six
what would black - because if black
takes what if just check over here
and if King goes to h8 well what I was
thinking was like just check and nice go
search seven and everything is safe and
sound
and now maybe just Queen g8 and I think
this would be the way for blacks to go
right yeah cuz I think this should be it
this way everything is protected for
whites and why just gets the chance to
keep the extra material well will you
take tonight
it's queen h6 take and if you try to
give the cheque the king can simply go
to h8 oops
h8 and 97 and even if you try to just
take on f4 well the king is still pretty
safe there could be potentially just
bringing the cleaner like Queen of fate
you give me another check I just block
it yeah all right so I'm glad that you
guys are agreeing on this all right so
that's why queen of six doesn't mark so
cleaner sticks doesn't work what else to
do so that's why I clean g3 is like the
only move to play I don't think Michael
needs to go to e4 after its queen takes
because if you play Knight e4 just
Knight takes your rook yeah
to answer Nixon you can't and to sorry
answer Brian Clark and yeah it is tunics
and you can't just may to the Queen but
we were just trying to see if the even
if there's like a perpetual or anything
yeah so Queen g3 is kind of forced but
you do have to calculate Queen of six
because there could be something and you
don't want to just mess it up because
you didn't do the calculation so Queen
goes to g3 and so now black plays rook
III so there are no media threats and so
I decided to play just Bishop here and
now black like English aids so now what
do you want to do with your night cuz
you see this night might be a little
misplaced yeah so I try to do some sort
of tactic here that kind of works and
there was another interesting way to
play this game so yeah just take a
minute and think about which what you
want to do
I'm still not only sing moves if Queen
nine takes d5 95 is interesting so let's
see what else do you have
Wow but doesn't black it another nice
Farouk exchange maybe not Brian Clark in
which position are you talking about in
this position you don't like 92 true
don't play 92 after Bishop d5 Bishop
efore so dij yeah you do have the
correct idea but instead of Bishop b4
Bishop c4 is more accurate so that's one
of the two possible outcomes so one one
thing that you can do is Knight takes d5
after take Bishop c4 and then if nice
comes to e4 which is like the only move
because if you move the bishop then it's
bye-bye clean time then you get the
chance to exchange and this is a
pleasant and game for kind of both
players and it's most likely going to
just be a just a boring draw honestly
so Brian I am not sure which position
you are referring to I see the comments
I just don't know which position you
were referring to 92 is 92 is the first
move that comes to mind in this position
but you shouldn't do it because my teach
you is really just so it's really
passive if you have to play 92 you might
as well try and just get more
sacrificial or any kind of active ideas
out so do you have any see any other
intermediate moves there is another cool
move that I saw in the game when I
played so what do you guys think about
intermediate so 95 is an interesting
move and it's definitely worth
considering but what do you think
anything else worth considering anything
intermediate who's coming up maybe
all right yeah
nish Nishant I believe yeah
rootkits you very good job so rookie two
is nice because it's intermediate move
and so the main thing that you have to
calculate is what if take well if take
win takes f4 and you're attacking the
rook in the night so it's quite pleasant
if you take here I give you check first
and this is really interesting I might
even be able to take this and have some
ideas with h7 maybe or if and yeah so
you take on f4 and you can also take on
h6 first and then take on f6 now you
have ideas to give check first and
there's a lot of lots and lots of ideas
so Ryan Lopez you are kind of funny but
no I don't thank you for your concern um
96 no 96 I mean this is something that
it's worth considering but you kind of
move on from it in a second
so like if 96 just taken you're out of
moves already so rookie to was what I
played and he she took on d3 so now now
what do you want to do with whites you
kind of have to take on d3 don't you G
takes here Queen takes turkey to Queen
f6 these are pretty standard news like
pretty forced so what do you do in this
position with white
man DJ sounds good
now to answer class well no it's not I
mean it's not disappointment it's just
like I'm not disappointed I'm trying to
explain the moves and trying to get you
to think about the moves somehow so
that's the next next one you say will be
kind of like you might you make the
candidate moves and you try to do the
calculations before shooting moves not
that you shoot means just in general so
yeah I think F for everyone is also
agreeing on it yep
f4 so whoever said you can't mate with
Queen was right you need other pieces so
your idea is clear you want to play a
rook to e3 so now what can you what
can't black to
not Thank You BZ Yankee where's my 50 K+
yeah so it is black to move what up what
should black to cuz we gotta try and
think about basements or opponent as
well right so yeah Thank You D AJ perky
six
so now after rook g3 the king can run
away another check and now what do you
want to do with white
it's white to move careful
yeah the chat is very energetic thank
you guys so yeah what do you want to do
with whites yep easy good one drew
create and same for Marcin anyone who
was thinking about it
good one recreates great so clean a six
is pretty much only move and the Queen a
six also has some ideas she could try
and create some things off her on so now
can someone tell me what to do with
whites because this is like you can't
see White has the upper hand
but at the same time you are piece down
so you got to figure something else
quickly
I feel like some of you guys are a
little behind because I'm just getting
to create ideas so yeah you guys are
going to be the root gh ones you are
correct I saw earlier look east six four
black - you were correct
- so yeah just tell me what you want to
do with white and if you're a little
behind and chat that's no problem at all
I see it and I know usually which
position you are referring to so Brian
rook e8 Oliver Rick e8 I have puncher
rook e8 ah my first rook d8 thank you
mala Chi Luke the eighth is more
interesting because you want to bring in
the Queen because if you just play rook
e8 then the King goes away and what do
you wanted to just keep checking now
your run out of checks now the king
could get to safe place near the bishop
so that's why rook the 8th is better
you cut the king and now you could try
and bring in like the Queen and then
maybe another check here and you just
create more opportunities so black
played Queen b6
I gave check and I took on h6 there was
another possibility like for example if
you play rook d7 that is also
interesting like c4 check King up and
you could like play something like this
as well this is also very interesting
because like white is attacking so many
things at once so yeah this was super
interesting as well however in the game
I played Queen takes h6 King h5 i so
yeah let's see what you want to do with
white
yeah I played Quidditch five honestly
and after take I gave this check and I
kind of just gave check shake hand we
need to draw especially because this was
wrong move 40 and I need at the time I
just gave a bunch of checks but I do
believe that there was something else
earlier so let's take a little bit let's
take of mmm little bits and figure out
if there was anything more here because
I do think there was something more but
only if you point G for King goes to e4
so what do you want to do after that
the King has kind of just getting away
and your rook is way behind it rook c5
doesn't really work which it takes d5
Queen h5 what is your idea the King has
so many squares to run into
yeah g4 doesn't feel very accurate
well that's what I was thinking maybe
Queen at seven but then what do you do
after King at four
whoops
oh don't know what is happening here
sorry just a second when I get back
okay no no Oh hold on what did I do
control one still kinda holds the
position a little too small okay
okay so this is what I was trying to
look at and yeah so for those of you who
know it yeah for those of you who were
saying something like with Queen h6 and
Queen age seven it's it's not really
working so we had this position that he
gave the check and then we were thinking
about something just with like with King
f5 and yeah Queen it whoa where's my
Queen go yeah hold on
I lost my queen ah there we go so I was
just trying to check and see if when
you're seven works but Queen er seven
doesn't seem to work by engine logic as
well just because King F 4 and if Queen
f7 then group comes to have six and
everything is just hold on so that's
like the problem and so yeah that's why
Queen f7 it doesn't actually work
we had the suggestion for Queen g5 King
h5 Queen g5 um I don't think this works
let's see what our friendly Frances
actually my friendly stockfish is
actually not being very helpful because
it keeps going back to move 1 so
nevermind failed experiment this laptop
doesn't really work with a functioning
engine learn my lesson and fix the board
I think Laura messed it up
alright so yeah that's why cleaner 7
didn't work why not Queen g5 but what do
you do after King efore that's the main
problem the King Keeks keeps running
away
maybe that's why rook d7 earlier was
better so the King keeps running away
and your rook is kind of cut out of
there so that is kind of why it's might
be easier to try this rook d7 earlier
and now if like there is a c4 you try
for this now at least your rook is
included in the game and there could be
C to XT files there could be f5 and that
there is like three three pawns versus a
versus a bishop just the repetition yeah
that's what I did in the repetition yeah
I did the repetition and yeah the
stockfish doesn't actually think that
you have to go back to move one which is
very kind of pisses me off
alright so after Queen h7 they have a
question which King takes g3 um the
other problem is when you play something
like g3 let's say the King comes to
let's say if King takes you want to play
route 3 8 there is always a struck g6
and this is kind of really uncomfortable
for white because you can't take it you
can't really like take here cuz like
there's also see force d4 is an ouch
yeah
so yeah clinched between h7 didn't work
so well glad we cleared that up now
let's see was there any other
suggestions
yeah stockfish kind of did suck a little
bit we did have this appear in Queens
and I'm not cheating I was trying to
explain the question to you thank you
for your understanding do I think
there's a psychological effect through
the opponent that is taller a buffer I
mean I'm pretty tiny so everyone's
pretty buffer than me anyways hand
taller than me
so I've learned to deal with it I don't
think there's a psychological effect no
I mean it could be force like super
beginners that they would feel the
bigger you are the better you are at
chess but it's all up here
so the Chess Club engines could be maybe
but ask a totally unrelated question so
the about how does one beat people with
bizarre openings I mean even though the
opening could seem bizarre that specific
person could know better chest and the
other person so it's not about the
opening all right so I think I've kind
of caught up on the questions to some
extent alright so yeah this is how the
game ended with perpetual because I just
couldn't figure out a way to bring in
the rook to help and I didn't have
enough material to attack the King so
yeah that is how it ended let's go to
the next one
all right let's look at a very cool and
game wise
all right so this one so remember how I
mentioned about Bishop b4 so after a 45
9 f3 knight c6 Knight f6 Knight c3 d4
and you get your d4 I forgot a move in
there whoops and you could opponent
doesn't have to take opponent can just
play Bishop before
so who does anyone here actually play
this with white or black
so the there's some little tricks
involved in with Bishop before because
the best the main line is to take on e5
and if Queen comes to e7 you have Queen
d3 and everything is just kind of pretty
chilled out and it's a whole whole kind
of openings that you can open if you
want to but you don't have to so in the
game I was actually playing 2600 plus
Grandmaster and I wasn't really feeling
opening confident wise so I just decided
to play something like d5 and it made
sense to me I was giving more space and
I liked the idea after 97 take night and
so the one thing that you kind of have
to keep in mind is this discipline is
going to fall so you're not winning upon
you're kind of like exchanging these
pawns down and so something like d6 I
played Knight f3 but Bishop e5 was way
more interesting intermediate moves you
guys and if c6 well there's the take
which I did c7 so c6 doesn't work if 97
now this is just pleasant position cuz
you're just one pawn up and there's
nothing else attacking your e4 so black
specimen would be to play King f8 and I
would just give back this e for pawn but
I would have given this check and the
King would have gone to f f8 and yeah so
Bishop b5 was more interesting but I
kind of chickened out and I played
Knight f3 after take Queen d4 bunch of
exchange Knight goes back c4 is kind of
really interesting as you keep your pawn
structure and you could have ideas with
bringing the bishop from b2 event
[Music]
yeah I was my opponent so it's like
nerado's I think I would he is from
Hungary I do have to flag up here so
don't have to think that much about it
and this was in be all tournament I only
got to play beer 2015 because 2069 had
some residency problems and 17 I had
moved here already
yep see that cool flag up there up here
yeah so that was my opponent will I do
d4 series hopefully yeah I would like to
be able to do that at some point okay so
back to the chest watch as I expect of
the game okay so after cast off so I'm
gonna ask you guys a little bit of
question so you do really like it's kind
of the first glance wise looks in more
interesting on black just because are
the two bishops on space but how can you
actually start using your your space and
your two bishops
how does someone get into a choice chess
tournament who is a beginner well
unfortunately right now there are no no
like physical tournaments so that's
could be a bummer for our beginner but
the Chess Club holds a lot of
tournaments there are a lot of other
tournaments happening online every day
so I would recommend that you join those
and give those a try
why not Knight f5 instead of Castille
well my top 5 isn't going anywhere so
you're not in a rush to play Knight f5
Bishop d3 Bishop g5
how do you get a legit rate it as I am
GM I don't think I understand the
question because like well it's kind of
well I I can't see why it would be
different a little then because in us
there's the USCF but you need to reach
the vidya minimum ratings to get the
titles and so I can see why that would
be a little complicated but so
I took a shower earlier today and I kind
of napped with my hair wet sorry
I am well and alive just a little runny
nose because of the forgetting to dry my
hair don't do that at home I apologize
for all of your ears I think when Simon
went there after that's nice you okay in
there
I am so sorry this is whoa I also have a
hot steaming team come tea coming up oh
sorry I've been in I'm in my house for
the past month or stuff so I'm okay just
okay thank you for all of your concern
and your wishes and okay I need to stuff
laughing cause when I love I kind of
cried right after my eyes get watery
okay let's get back to whoa for nice
makes everyone cry right okay so why to
move we have a bunch of suggestions
Bishop g5 and Bishop d3 and stuff so
Bishop d3 is what I point I think Bishop
g5 is playable as well but I my main no
I'm good are you good I see little blood
coming out of your ears okay
I'm kidding here's fine I wanted to
believe it ship g5 but my biggest
problem was I don't know if I want this
Bishop to be on g5 or if I wanted to be
on b2 so that's why I was kind of
delaying it so after castle I played
Bishop d3 and now black White Knight to
f5 if I take it black takes and I mean
everything about blacks position is nice
or well I could try to give this check
which is also very unpleasant and like
the only way to try and keep the King
from not like getting on Castille
there's maybe Bishop e6 but again like
take and like if you make the castle
there could be e5 s and this is getting
a little too unpleasant for whites so
yeah
that's why I don't take it on I just
play the Queen of four check I had to
play King f1 onward for unfortunately
cuz if like Bishop e2 there could be
always something like Queenie 7 and it's
good it's not really looking good for
white if Bishop e3 there's take and this
is just getting really unpleasant for
whites
so King f1 97 I finally managed to get
my Bishop out he got his horsey out
whoops oh my god I keep doing my lips
today okay I'm back in the same position
all right
97 Bishop b2 Knight gets out Queen g5
going after this guy 97 now it's white
to move what do you do so while you guys
are thinking about this I go back and
read some comments because I kind of
shied away from the chat a little after
my it's you
well thank you I actually did tie my
hair today that's another reason my eyes
are a little watery because a lot of
chemicals around thank you Jim for your
nice comment I don't really mind the
jokes but I I'm not particularly a big
fan of it either let's see
oops I do not speak eye that might be
German could be Turkish I don't speak
either of them unfortunately yeah of
course
oh yeah it does help linic
bishop beats you cool i like the idea of
Bishop b2 um Kenny Castle queenside oh
you see if I was playing with like a
1600 with someone much lower rated I
might have done like one Castellon
attack attack but when I was since I was
playing a guy who was like 400 points
more than me I didn't really want to
risk it to be honest I didn't want to
give too much William G thank you for H
for let's see who else gave me Queen h5
is interesting but one thing that you
need to realize is you gotta get this
jerk out and one of the easiest way to
get the rook out is this ideally so
that's that's something to keep in mind
um be easy that is funny who would play
chess
I actually I haven't been playing as
much tournament since I became college
students but I it was like not last
night the night before that I did have a
very detailed dream of a chess
tournament happening in the club and I
was all dressed up and I'll prepared and
I knew my openings and everything I was
going to the game and the tournament got
canceled as soon as I was walking in and
I was so pissed in my dream so here goes
chess dream thank you for all of your
kind words yeah so why did I play Bishop
III right after rook e1 Bishop e3 the
Knights on f5 would have made this
really unpleasant and the bishop on b2
is way more stronger so he took on g5 so
another thing to consider with h4 is
that issuer is nice mainly because if
take you take with H and you you give a
purpose to your drug and if he wouldn't
take now let's say Knight c5 you had h5
and if this nice moves
well the ninth cancer they go back cause
of g7 square if Knight goes to e5 that's
another pawn that might be coming up for
white yay so yeah so the one thing that
I was trying to kind of like play I was
trying to play it's safe but at the same
time trying to keep it dynamic so I
didn't really want to make it too too
complicated for my understanding but I
wanted to make it complicated so it
wouldn't be an easy game for my opponent
that's something that I usually do when
I'm playing with like a much higher
rated y higher y h4 if you could
exchange Queens well because I wanted to
exchange Queens in my own terms I didn't
him to pick how to exchange coins I
wanted this exchange I wanted my pawn to
be on g5 to answer Nishant Rae Lopez you
are really on fire today aren't you
I have few Persians here thank you for
watching it how do you pick the opening
to use well actually
this game specifically was kind of funny
I will tell you the story right after we
get to our next thinking position which
is here why to move what do you want to
do while you guys think I'll tell you
the story
so I remember this was the first time I
played bill open I was there with my mom
and my brother and my brother was also
playing and everything was like cool and
I remember that I was very close to
crossing 2300 which I think it happened
in this tournament and I don't I did I
know I didn't I didn't get my wgm norm
here unfortunately but I remember it was
the this was the first round and I I
went to the playing hall and I expected
to see that the pairings before because
I was still used to seeing the parents
before like few hours before the game
and like looking I put the opponent
plays and all of those stuff so I
decided to actually take my laptop so as
soon as I knew who was playing I could
just look up what he plays but
unfortunately you had Wi-Fi problems so
that didn't happen but I was prepared so
that was kind of funny because I do like
to know I like to be prepared to some
extent and I wanted to have that comfort
of knowing what my opponent plays
beforehand or at least the possibility
of what he plays so as soon as I saw I
was planning a 2600 I think it was like
on board 9 or 10 I was playing I was
like aha
well can't even prepare now and after he
played a 45 I I have prepared some four
nights previously so I just played that
all right so that was the story of how I
choose to play an opening this one I
kind of chose over the board
to play for Knights cuz I wasn't a big
four-night player back in 2014-15 I
started to grow 2015 as a devoted for
Knight player okay what about 9 3 5 no
95 is possible but do you want this pawn
here because you want to give you a rook
a purpose
g3 maybe but so the main question is do
you want this night to take so your pawn
gets here or you want to like take on g6
now because you do have options g3 is
interesting Knight e4 is interesting so
all of these moves are interesting but
Bishop takes g6 is the stronger one yeah
because you don't want to play like g3
take take and Bishop f5 and you're
spending eternity just trying to keep
your stuff together like very passively
and it's just not worth it so the other
thing is you want to take on g6 we also
play wreckage for to bring out your rook
in the game I did consider a move like
rook d1 which is also interesting but it
gives a chance with Bishop g4 and I
wanted to avoid that it is still it's
still very doable position but why give
this Bishop g4 idea when you can just
play Rica Shore and take away the square
did i win this game no it ain't gonna
draw
I think g3 is coming up but the order of
moves playing playing rock h4 first is
more interesting just because you take
away that the g4 Square firm Bishop and
then you are going to try and play g3
and then King comes to g2 and all those
fun stuff so he tried with b6
Bishop Asics King up another kind of
cool thing about Turkish words that
you're already protecting your c4 pawn
and it's just really nice you're
protecting your c49
upon your rook has a purpose to h7 is
under attack
so everything isn't cool 97 ruk h1
tonight f8 pretty much the only way to
keep age 7 alive I decided to go with
Bishop c3 just because I wanted to take
away more squares on this time file and
also so now it's white to move this is
so now this is also a mix of end games
so maybe give it a try and tell me how
you want to play this end games we have
looked at bunch of endgame puzzles
together recently so I expect some good
answers
make me proud guys all right let's go
back to the chat while we're doing here
so Marcin is asking why worship Jesus is
stronger because you took on g6 to open
up that trick h4 idea because if not
your bishop would always be under attack
and Bishop taking on g6 was a better
exchange than the Knights taking the
bishop on d3 yeah say it Marty you are
correct a4 good one let's think about
let's let's see what else I had iPad
pulsar
I speak beautiful English with Farsi
accent ah cool thank you what did I get
here 2017 when I start chess when I was
6
for yeah god I'm getting old
[Music]
thank you thank you Jim Henderson that
is very nice of you to answer the chat
all right oh wow
glad to know these are still plus twenty
six hundred ninety-four looks really
natural yeah that is true 94 is a very
cool move to play but kind of be careful
cuz if 94 there's the take and then this
guy is under attack so another big
problem is okay so White's play White's
game is in the kingside right
Black's game is going to try to be in
the center or in the queenside so what
can whites do to try and kind of bother
black so it the best way to try to Noah
black is to try and like create some
game in the queenside
because if as whites you have control in
the King side and coincide then you
already have the upper hand
right so pay for it fruit goes to e8 now
you push more so
if black were to take now this is kind
of pleasant cuz you have this guy under
attack and now you could potentially
start moving around with the knife just
you get to get a lot of chances so
that's why black played d5 taking seems
like the natural way right because it
but pushing doesn't really seem to be
doing anything reasonable now I I just
wanted to try and bring in my knight
somewhere but it still doesn't work
because if 94 there is a still Bishop c4
and my deeper d5 pawn is is still
hanging so I just hold on I'm not gonna
tell you this now why to move you do
know that this d5 pawn being all lonely
is a problem how do you want to fix it
yeah that's okay
to answer a mother's gamer well I'm not
trying to threaten anything I'm just
trying to make blacks black a little
uncomfortable
that's all I'm not I know that there's
not it's not going to be a decisive
that's what happened you just kinda
ignored a five he put it be five but
okay let's go back to the five what
happens if he ignores it well nothing
I'm not going to take it he's not going
to take it was chill I'll play 92 and
who knows maybe 93 I don't really have a
decisive plan he doesn't have any
decisive plan either so it was just a
matter of who wants to push more so yeah
so the idea Knight d2 is very nice and
you want to play c4 so what do you want
to do with your bishop cuz your Bishop
is on the way
so what do you want to do what's your
move order
the so we have combined both classes of
the choice on psychology and our insane
and endgame one so I'm going to explain
more for night and games not as insane
as you expect but it is it is pretty
cool to know these there's a question
about if I do know your other years I
fear this job had this question of
course I know him but the kid I remember
was he a high and so it's like super
tiny and skinny so not him anymore I did
never haven't played him but my younger
brother has and they had I prepared my
brother for when they had tournaments
together so that was kind of cool um
what else
yeah so you want to move the fish up and
you want to bring in the king so move
the bishop sorry not the king tonight
and bring in the night
so now black tried to play something
like c6 and I did my c4 take take black
plays Bishop a6 could be some ideas with
Bishop going to be seven now you are
white what do you want to do
ah we shall have six sacrifices it'll is
a little um too much that's true you
can't remove this stuff
so not Bishop f6 Bishop b2 is
interesting but what do you want to do
with the night he wants to because you
kind of do know where this night belongs
you want to play Knight c4 right because
if you were if you put something like 94
it's possible but um you know a little
bit whoopsie
so yeah basically what do you want to do
with your night might c4 is the most
logical one because if take you just
take with jerk and now your rooks are
active in both sides so Knight c4 yeah
bringing the rook to be one on v4 is
also interesting but you gotta play your
knight c4 first cuz you know you know
where your knife belongs and after night
c4 you were attacking d6 so rookie to
black is trying to activate his pieces
and put them in the 7th ranked second
7th rank and now what so the idea of
might be one night sitter is interesting
but it's way too passive you need to
play more active because even if you put
your knight on c3 what do you want to do
with your Bishop on a1 so yeah the idea
of Knight e3 was also well it so if
Knight if Bishop goes there and Knight
e3 is possible but you gotta be careful
with stuff like this because also
attacking h1 and also messing up with
your pawn structure and already eating
upon so you gotta be very careful with
these thank you thank you for the kind
words from Peru no one I can read that I
am so sorry but thank you I do have ones
with Peruvian friends there's they're
always being super nice okay so rookie
to what do you want to do with white you
want to take d6 okay rook d8 what now
whoa the chat is exploding cool white
trucks look like they're not taking part
in the game true I gotta bring them back
in great things from Canada thank you
greetings from st. Louis with just
community in Germany I wish I was in
Germany yeah it was pretty cool I didn't
play German Bundesliga Michael with
Austria Bundesliga that was nice
what's my next tournament well I was
supposed to go US Championship and it
was supposed to be ending you know these
days but that got postponed so I don't
know what's my next tournament until
there are tournaments to play hopefully
as soon as them it gets under control we
can get back to us championships and
there are other tournaments but
okay so Rajat Sharma you have problems
using plans while then deciding which
plan is better any suggestions
ya make candidate moves so when you make
your candidate news it kind of
eliminates bunch of the moves already so
that's good
94 is correct we should be seven now
what do you want to do back to Rajat the
best thing that helped me try to decide
which one to play was trying to make a
habit out of making candidate moves and
to try to make habit out of like
evaluating the position the other thing
that kind of helped me make this this
kind of decisions was how to how to like
which move that I play which plan that I
play will make my opponents feel more
press than more miserable so that's kind
of why I like the way I make most of my
plans so if if this specific plan makes
you more uncomfortable as my opponents
then that's most likely what I'm going
to do so maybe that's something you can
try
okay greetings from Kenya thank you
maybe e4 c5 c6 Jim which position are
you considering maybe Bishop C 3 and B 4
nice
maybe another piece to c3 instead of the
bishop n yeah Knight c3 so Bishop c3 is
interesting but the big thing is you
don't you do not want to give this
bishop this monstrous monstrous diagonal
so that's why you kind of played Knight
c3 to keep this diagonal to yourself if
tank cool you just take it and now there
are no more dangers for your position so
yeah you gotta kind of keep that d5 pawn
protected king of stroke e4 oh yeah all
right so after let's say everything's
changed I tried to how they say activate
my rooks just as he was activating his
rooks cuz I started to lose bunch of
pawns and I couldn't stop it
so right now why to move how do you want
to keep activating why not get a free
temper with King f3 because King f3
there was always this rookie fours and
then Bishop d5 I think hold on I could
go back thank you thank you I liked
being in India alright so we had a
question about here King f3
nevermind looking for doesn't working no
looking for does work if King takes in
who are just bishop here and bye-bye a
piece and if rook takes still Bishop
takes d5 and even if our key one even if
take take this is still similar it's
king after you would
even if it's possible it doesn't it
doesn't have that much effect so that's
why I just wanted to get rid of that
strong Bishop so we have work be one
suggestion all right so I went to Roxy
one break f5 check exchanged and I took
in I offered the drawing and we accepted
it
what's my favorite opening GU playing
against French Oh below Oh Algerian med
student yeah I want to be a med students
good feeder I think thank you thank you
for your watching
alright so this was one of the highest
rated that I've ever drawn so that was
kind of cool and it wasn't like a lost
position that I pulled something out it
actually went it actually went pretty
decent all the game and I was kind of
proud of myself but I could hold the
game all throughout
alright ready for another fun draw a lot
of these end games are going to be
dryish so don't be disappointed but
that's the beauty of four night I'm
trying to load the next one okay this
one let's look at this one
so I played don't offer draw well doc
that position was really draw what do I
play against French a4 a6 d4 d5 Knight
c3 it really depends on what opponent
does but alright so this is another game
that I had so this is what a typical for
nights end game should look like
so take take Bishop before you exchange
Bishop d3 d5 you exchanged castle castle
you get the bishop out remember in the
game with John SIA I played a stray but
in this game Bishop g5 wind f3 and this
is the typical way to get your pieces
out usually let's see so story about
this game so this game was in 2015 World
Junior Championship in 20 months I think
yeah this was the last round I think I
had scored my norm and I knew I didn't
have a chance for medal I ended up after
this game after making a draw I think if
I won I would get fourth place if I drew
I would get sixth place which was kind
of like burning because I wanted the
middle I did get a medal but for a sixth
place I wanted like a medal for you know
gold silver bronze stuff like that so I
wanted to try my best but there wasn't
that much to fight for honestly and it
was very unfortunate for me but anyways
so one of my most favorites maneuvers
with Knight is this one you get your
night to e1 and in this end game now the
night is going to start doing some fun
jumping's and attack this guy so about
French I have shown a bunch of French
games so feel free to check those up
you'll see my style in those if not I
can try and do more French next week but
right now let's focus on our four nights
in the end games because they're
actually very nice how do I build my
chess repertoire it's kind of buy time
my style changed a lot so I tried to
figure out what I like and what I don't
like
so that's something
um really helped me so like four nights
when I was when I was younger I hated it
because it wasn't game and I hated nks
but when I got slightly better in end
games I actually understood then this
end game with four nights on I just just
I liked it why not
so you know my idea we are doing this
idea pretty clearly around black kind of
does have to take cause if King is seven
then this is a disaster it's Bishop f8
is also a possibility but there are lots
of other hassles that could be possible
something like f4 and bringing the rook
here so that's another possibility
okay so alright so she took kind of best
known Rick eats you know they're not
many moves left in the position so I'm
going to ask you the first and probably
last question out the position what do
you want to do with whites i yes that's
actually to answer crunch yeah this is
actually one of the biggest ideas for
night because in this endgame if black
plays it's accurate all right
most likely going to be a draw because
of the pawn structure and because of the
the way the pawns and the bishops are
placed and they are the idea is that I'm
going to putting my Knights on f5 if you
take it all right that's what I wanted
if not then my h6 is falling so you are
creating chances for opponent to make
mistake its d4 by black to play to stop
94 d4 as possible but then C 4 square
would be a really big hole so that would
be 9 P to Knight c4 oh thank you rickets
rook to e3 yeah
yep nope unfortunately I mean kind of
fortunately for me this was a draw
well do you want this bishop you want
this bishop to stay with f5 because you
have another thing in four-night that is
very common is this idea you give this
check and you are either taking a pond
or it's a draw so yeah I was just going
to show you what a typical four night
endgame should look like so this is when
both white and black made the best moves
and that's actually how the game ended I
know a little too dry but most likes
more exciting than lots of other
openings and games right okay so any
questions on this one before we move on
to the other openings that we have other
games with four nights that we have
no nothing all right so I'm gonna move
to the next one if there were any
questions we can always come back I had
a kind of cool game room I played Aryan
Chopra for my Indian friends in the chat
I think yeah he I do believe at the time
he was a grandmaster just reached 2500
but it was a nice kid
so I played this game in Gibraltar 2017
and I was 23 17 he was like 25 a little
above 25 if I remember correctly and so
I played my famous for Knight style
again
so everything similar to the last one
until move ten move 12 instead of
playing with p8 earlier raft and then
pushing 91 he played h6 first it is
similar idea so now remember how last
game I played my see one 93-91 Knight c3
Knight f5 well this one I try to do it
slightly differently similar ideas but
slightly different so what do you want
to do with whites yes this is a cup of
tea cold now but yeah I owe you guys
know I like my black teas
how can you sing in a tournament if you
win it they might allow you to sing on
stage whites now in that position white
couldn't press anymore in this game that
I'm showing you I could press more I
chickened out you know we all have those
moments that we kind of chickened out I
am but yeah unfortunately this was one
of my whoops I chickened out
I do have Instagram shouldn't be that
hard it's it's public so yeah II 2 G 3 F
5 yes - e - no - g 3 yes - f 5 so I
played 92 my idea was well if you let me
I'll come to G 3 if not I can just go to
d4 so if something like c5 I thought
this would make this pawn also weaker
and it was a good good Hoddy say
provocative to play the c5 but he would
wreck I ate I got my Knight d4 now I'm
attacking this guy and after Bishop e7
Knight f5 white already has a slight
advantage because now I got my knight to
where I want it and you're both of your
bishops are looking kind of weird
they're not really serving any purpose
so this is the better version of what we
saw in the previous game the previous
game the game I had against dinara she
played the best moves I played the best
moves and it ended in a draw this one I
played the good I played very good news
Arion chopra didn't play good news
unfortunately and I had advantage but I
chickened out so let's see how I I
didn't chicken out who watch what
happened
I'm kind of liking the term of
chickening out okay
why Bishop disavow Bishop d7 and not d7
no idea I think Bishop d7 would happen
more practical I think he wasn't very
familiar or comfortable with this
endgame so he didn't know what to expect
even though he was a grandmaster I don't
think he knew what to look for that's
just a feeling I got over the board if
90 to see if I would I play c3 and chill
no I would still go with Knights g3 I
didn't want to play C 3 because if C 3
then in the long run my B to pawn is
really weak a4 takes the rook on a 8
no no remember so what was the big idea
that we tried in the last game one of
the big ideas with the rook coming to
third rank yeah we're going to try for
rook g3 good one i crush so I I went to
jerky three take take and now I'm
getting the chance to bring up my rook
key points e5 because c5 now c4 might be
coming up
so now just b3 chill so see if I were to
play c3 this pawn is going to be very
delicious for black so this is just
giving black an immediate threat which
I'm not willing to give that easily
that's why b3 would be more legit all
right so b3 work goes to e8 now what do
you want to do with whites
I sleep on not a big deal no not really
because this is actually um it's kind of
stopping the d-force so it's not really
a big deal because also black cancer the
attack it
this night is protecting it everything
seems to be under control so yeah look
at 5:00 work of three those are the
moves you're going to go play now so for
example rook F for Bishop c8 now what do
you want to do with white oh well good
night
iPad iPad Pulsar thank you for watching
I was great to have Persian community
here too
well if you play Bishop b5 it's possible
but you kind of have to be careful of
this night because Ricky five what do
you want to do if you move the Knights
III Falls if you don't move the knight
there is a take and then take on III so
no not this should be fine
Luke G for check it's possible but what
do you do after king of shades the fruit
cage for there could always be just take
and an III is falling so let me ask you
another probable question if it's black
to move again what does black wants
black wants to take on f5 and take on e3
right so III is your weakness so try to
defend that yeah good one Adam King f2
yeah look F 3 instead of rook f4 was
also interesting but I think it's
similar ideas you do have to bring out
the King eventually anyways so why not
just do it now
Yeah right it's keeping the position
together this is a classic whole game by
the way yeah doors are classical 2017
the ideals are very classical and I
learned these ideas by watching
classical games but now it's it's a it's
one of my personal collections so well
after rookie five what do you want to do
with your night do you want to keep the
horsey here you want to move it to h4 g3
what do you want to do efore mm okay the
problem with E 4 is take we take with
Bishop there's rook takes rook takes and
you that's better for black rook g4 is
worth considering but it's not going to
work because the King goes away and your
knight is a still pinned and you kind of
have to come back
g4 um g4 is possibly interesting but
after take take you don't have that edge
anymore your your bishop
your knight is stronger than his bishop
so it's a good idea to try and keep
tonight by pushing it pull it like
putting it somewhere else like h4 g3
no time control yeah it was classical
this was in Gibraltar I do have another
I do have some cool rapid games that I
could show you okay so in this position
what I did was not g3 but it was better
to play Knight h4 because 9h for I am
threatening with Knight f3 so if you
were to play like Bishop comes to a 7
I'd have this Knight f3 so okay and then
oh yeah this light after is pretty cool
because if you were to play like Kirk f5
per se I have okay for and I'm going
after this pawn woops sorry rook
air-five sorry I meant Rick h5 again you
have route a4 and you're going for this
a 7 so that's another idea so even
though that's so looking back back back
as when I played Rick f4 Ruka for
another idea was to keep an eye on both
Kings side and the Queen side so that's
another thing I fight nice g3 because I
wanted to keep my knight safe and sound
here and go with your k4 he played
Bishop e7 this is where I chickened out
I I chickened out by Knight f5 and the
repetition
I knew sometimes happens the best of us
but I should have played Rick a fort
because after rook a for now I'm
actually taking a pawn
so what can I do
either of the electric age 5 or Luke
ecigs anything that was possible to try
and go for Luke a 4 but yeah I think
rakesh 5 g 4 is very strong and yeah
g 4 works i thought maybe there's a
bishop t6 never mind
yeah so I put it that I should have
played this through K 4 and I'm taking
on a 7
so what black can't do is black could
play something like c4 but and now I
could just take and enjoy my one pawn up
or I could also take over here because
if you were to take this pawn there are
district 8/8 that if you take I take and
then I just take this one as well so
would be very pleasant
and I think this was something that I
kind of missed in the game this idea
with Drew k-8 and King f3 just I think
this is what I missed in the game and I
thought this would be uncomfortable but
this is a very winning end game actually
so that was my mistake that I didn't
push for more but as you can see there
is so much to push for and it's just
white is very comfortable black is the
one who's trying to gain something I
continue to look into what could happen
so this was actually engine line after
because I in the game I couldn't decide
what to do after Bishop c5 when I gave
up on the line in this position and
laughter I was analyzing and I realized
that I could just play like King f3 and
go into this cool weird line oh good
night Peter thank you for staying with
us alright
so this was another game of me
chickening out because I couldn't
calculate enough and I didn't have an
engine in my brain but if it was now I
would most likely push for more and try
my best to get something out of the
position yeah ah Thank You Nixon you
always always make me proud alright
how can you sign in the tournament's um
there are a lot of online tournaments
happening every single day so feel free
to check those out
but I don't really there are no real
tournaments happening right now because
of cold width so I am sorry for last
yeah that's true sometimes I do chicken
out all right next one
I give me one second oh this is a this
is an interesting one um give me a
second
to see if it was actually moving up this
was a this was a sad one actually i
blundered meat oh let's look at another
different version of similar line all
right
so this is again in the same tournament
different grandmaster he actually does
lots of videos for different websites so
he was very nice and yeah very very
interesting game I didn't chicken out
the position required both of us
chickening out how long do you play for
I think I lost in the conversation
[Music]
Papa John's is to give okay I'm gonna go
back to chest cuz sometimes Chad can be
really lost all right okay so take take
Bishop before take take everything
similar I believe this one is with the
Bishop e7 one so remember with John SIA
the first time I showed you I played a
ch3 but the rest I play Queen at f3 and
now it should be seven so after Bishop
d7 there are no more ideas with h6
because I take it and just Bishop takes
so after that I still played the rook e1
now if h6 I'm most likely would still
take and oh no sorry I would take that
cuz oh yeah that's a cool line I
actually did this line saw on an online
game recently that was cool so and this
is also another funny perpetual because
it just take here and you're going to
give purpose show on g5 and h6 so c4
Knight has bunch and bunch of Perpetual
's right okay am I prepared for the 960
tomorrow
oh no I looked up some YouTube videos I
still have to you look more and play
some games before our ranks you playing
online tournament I rank I get can
towards dream tournaments I don't think
so
one of the problems with covet rights
now for chess community is that you
can't play anywhere to increase your
federating to be able to achieve feeder
titles so that's a problem and I hope if
it's going to ask more months maybe fee
they could come up with something but
that also increases the chance of
unethical games so I don't know in at
this at this moment I don't really have
a good solution for the problem
those who need feeder grating and
feeding norms to get their titles my
brother is one of these guys right now
he needs a little bit more norms and a
little bit more racing to get this I am
but yeah anyways so we got this fun
position so this is a very kind of dry
position but as you saw within the game
that I had with John SIA it could
actually get through the interesting so
as white is your job to just stop
whatever opponents is doing right so
this ship might want to come to jeepers
so let's stop it now let's just develop
very chilled out now that's why to move
what do you want to do
Oh emaddix
no it's not how the game went with h6 I
wish it this it would have been so cool
but no that's just something that I knew
how are we going to share your time
playing in the tournament I haven't
figured out the logistics yet but I
think I will be like we will be playing
few games each I'm I'll let you know
when we know more I read earlier about
grocery shopping oh my god I want
pistachio ice cream so bad that I
actually made a small trip to Whole
Foods yesterday and I found pistachio
ice cream it was so good I ate the hook
open so yeah that just thought that's
worth sharing while you guys are
thinking I am a huge fan of pistachio
pistachio ice cream saffron pistachio
ice cream yeah I it's really hard to
find those here stack rooks it is coming
up
but what do you want to do with your
bishop right now do you want to just
keep it here you want to take it do you
want to try and change it in a little
better position nice eh - yeah
ninety-two was one of the ideas that I
had I didn't play 92 though
okay so Bishop e5 is what I went for my
idea was very simple you take I take and
now I want us as like double my rooks up
here clean b8 what do you do as white
now my married I'm twenty-two why would
I be me RIT married to my work and my
studies if that makes sense that I'm
getting really funny comments today
aren't I
be careful your rook is under attack so
what do you want to do so rook e1 is
interesting but if you play rook e1 then
there is queen bee - so maybe something
else something a little bit oh yeah I
married to pistachios
I wish they're hard to come by that the
comments are this chat is I think
definitely my most interesting so far
just keeps getting more and more right
alright so what do you want to do here
with whites we have bunch of rookie one
oh I have a queen g3 good thank you yeah
Queen g3 is the the trickier way to put
it simply and so the problem is well
blacks not going to take here because
the Queen would be way way too far off
and there could be rookie ones and Queen
has to go to any tree and this is just
uncomfortable position for black you
don't want to have that bit black
there could be visual 5s coming up and
there's just lots and lots of
possibilities so that's why Queen takes
b2 is not the best one and it would just
lose lots of activities so we do have a
moderator I guess these are okay so
be easy I have been mentioning you all
along
how much more comments you got haven't
you run of the stuff yet do I like this
that's just okay who is my favorite GM
Fabiano
okay so who in g3 he bites King h8 just
to get out of the fire stuff and be able
to take here with attacking c3 so at
this point I just played b3 and I'm just
keeping my pawns intact I might try to
play Knight to c5 just a bunch of ideas
so yeah well to answer in Maddox it is
possible but you kind of want that clean
to be on g3 because if Queen takes b3 if
your rook is on e 1 you just go back to
be 1 and you're losing at MP so I hope
that answers your question
okay so b3 clean counts to be 4
what do you want to do with white
keep in mind that you kind of want to
bring up more pieces to the kingside to
try and develop some sort of attack
who is the highest rated player I played
I have played few 2,700 haven't scored
anything in the 2,700 yet unfortunately
I have scored 2600 guys come on why did
this marriage questions are really
ridiculous would you ask me the same
things if I was a guy and would you ask
me marriage questions about this is not
nothing it's it was fun in the beginning
no more thank you though
thank you for your interest but no thank
you
okay 92 yes thank you thank you for your
nightie twos okay so 92 is good because
you are just deciding to go to f4 maybe
play see 394 lots of lots of good ideas
alright so 92 yeah you have lots of
stuff to go great
so 92 Bishop he bought Bishop d7 I
actually think Bishop d7 is good because
honestly the other move that could be
considered is something like d4 but d4
just to like completely close up
everything here but then the problem is
at night f4 you are giving me way too
much room to jump around with my knight
so I think Bishop d7 was very smart idea
now if if I take it then okay now your
rook so remember how we were talked
about the idea of like when to exchange
so this is one of those times like one
of those times that we can think about
what to exchange when to exchange is now
so right now think about it as Black's
perspective so if black was
if black had the upper hand black would
be trying to avoid exchanges but this
trick here is actually quite strong so
it's my one of my active pieces and this
truck is better than the d1 works so
that's why we try to exchange it as
black could I explain purpose of having
the Queen and jittery other than
somewhere else
well queena f3 was interesting but Queen
and g3 kind of holds everything together
and it's also keeping an eye on g7 it's
not that much of a difference but I
queen g3 just went a lot with the rhythm
that's honestly the best thing I can
explain it hi laughs ooh and so the
thing is that Queen to g3
its it is really active here you can't
really find any if your queen was on f3
where else would you want your Queen to
be III as possible but it will always be
in the line of fire so that's why it
would be better on g3 but I understand
why it would be confusing cuz it's not
serving any direct purpose right now
alright so yeah dan post thank you c3 go
on
thank you Ricketts good one c3 let's say
Queen goes to a3
now what do you want to do because keep
in mind you don't want to let the Queen
eat all of your pants because even
though you are more active you don't
have like a decisive win so you
shouldn't want to exchange everything
off you don't want to start giving out
pieces and pawns why not pawn to g5
so even if you don't see Mohammed face
out even if you don't see anything
immediate with what's wrong with g5 the
least of all g5 would be giving white a
clear targets wise can start exploring
it at age 4 with f4 but a bunch of
different stuff h6 is weak the so that's
why g5 shouldn't be played for black
mainly because it gives up so many
targets you make life you make White's
life easy basically so that's what you
don't want to do the Queen is passive on
a tree so let's try to keep it that way
rook takes possible night c1 now then I
shouldn't come to see one Bishop e1
maybe but why not risky to wood f4 be a
good move before nights eat you know
because you want your night to go to eat
you you want your night to go to f4
Timothy thank you yeah rook D - Thank
You Maddux yeah rook T - so the idea
with rook t2 is quite interesting if you
take I'll just stick with the Queen my
queen is centralized everything feels
chills right so what if something like a
five what do you do then
so it's watching we were just trying to
improve your position so I have a
suggestion
so I have a question actually in to play
like Bishop b12 want to play Queen ed3
[Music]
the problem is if you play Bishop you
want take take through p8 and this guy
is falling
you could try like Queen come back to g3
but take in rookie for so yeah that's
why Bishop e1 doesn't work because this
guy gets super weak so that's why rook
d2 now Rigney to a5 now what do you want
to do with what
you would give up your queen stipend
well that's one of the things that it's
good that you're sayings so I can give
you some insight well clutch the thing
is if you give up your queen size pawns
you are giving your opponent easier game
that's basically it even though if you
don't have even though if you have like
it cool possibility of an attack you
would make your life a minute you would
make your opponent's life easier because
your opponent would have a clear path of
what to do when to do what to push what
to take it would make it so much easier
so wicked Thank You King edge - Thank
You Alan Thank You Marcin all of you
thank you yeah
so you basically wants to play nine to
four but you can't because of Queen
Alana a queen c1 and bye-bye rook so you
play King gage - thank you King gage -
rook takes d5 Queen takes d5 rook e8 I
played Queen at four because I didn't
want to deal with Queen d4 I thought
there might be I didn't want to give
this possibility of check and possible
c5
so I just want to place my clean and f4
yeah exactly
okay so at this point he played Queen c5
so question for you guys in the chat
what would you do it's c5
um
[Music]
it marks which position ah and thank you
Queen d6 here so yeah
Queen d6 here is good Queen c7 is also
good I prefer clean d6 because it kind
of just paralyzes your position as black
your queen is stuck your pawns are even
though not directly under attack you
can't really push anything either of
them so I really really like this Queen
d6 idea yeah the Queen is getting low on
squares right so that's why he played
Queen c5 now why to move what do you do
yeah so Queen c7 so it Queen c5 think
about I don't want to give up the move
but how can you try and push your
position how can you try and break
through with whites maybe because your
bishop your bishop is good your knight
could be better but not right now cuz
this pawn is hanging your rook needs to
be better but again knots right now cuz
where to go so you need another move to
try and open up the position a little
bit before Thank You Timothy
yeah thank you Marcin before so before
is actually quite pretty if you take it
here I can take it with this guy and now
it's a wee time I've done this a lot in
the twitch stream see people seem to
like it but anyways yeah you get the
chance to start pushing this pawn you
can bring out your roof now everything
gets a nice flow right okay so that's
why he didn't take you play its Queen 87
now why to move what do you do
yeah you get a patent you would get a
passed pawn if you took it so what do
you want to do now with white it is
strong position of motive true thank you
yeah yep maybe maybe it's at some point
we get some pushy pushy - thank you I
felt like a beast but not for long
though because he found the good news
and I kind of had to dance to his music
a tree interesting take on a five no you
want to try and tempt your opponent to
take with B 4 so you have both of the
pawns Knight d4 if you move this night
you have to be careful because something
like rookie one could always pop up so
be careful with that a tree interesting
the problem is if you play a three if he
takes you cannot take it with because a
three is falling so that's why a three
students really so I have a bunch of
suggestions of 94 but what about Queen D
for this hunt game would be better for
white right because if you take I'm
going to take and now I'm directly
attacking your pawn and I'm going to
attack it on to I you kind of have to
take it and I would have the passed
pawns so that's why Queen d4 is the most
interesting one even though I used to
hate end games I thought I can't play
without my queen I've improved it and
queen d4 is the way to go because this
end game is better for white so Queen d4
and the other thing is Queen d4 is
actually what the position needs and so
after Queen d4
my opponent was a grandmaster so of
course it didn't take on d4 he just
played Queen c7 check and after Queen c7
the idea is quite clear Queen c7 if I
touch my Knights
clear weakness there could be nice 5s
there could be Queenie files there could
be just it's a weakness and you don't
want to give that weakness if i play my
g3 is same
I'm giving up this rookie one I'm giving
up this Knight age five and again bunch
of weaknesses if I play g3 oh god oh god
worse this is another humongous weakness
over here could be even be queen c8
going after this one so any games could
be scary yeah yeah that's the fear I had
with Queen c7 so I decided to repeat and
see what he thinks and he wanted to keep
repeating so what can I say
and that's actually how the game ended
because in this position Queen d4 is the
best move and here again Queen afore is
the best move so I can't really I
couldn't really I didn't want to go
against the position and he played good
with black I played good with white it
was a very well-deserved result for both
of us
yeah that's that's that's actually
actually what happened he didn't make
any mistakes I didn't make any mistakes
so yeah I what's wrong with f4 they're
way too many holes here let's see is
there an the Hadi think about Knights h5
oh hold on what do you feel a whoa 94
what do you think about 94
yeah f4 is to weakening and if you take
it just work takes and bye-bye this guy
even if you don't take it it's this guy
and that guy yeah yeah I did my best he
did his best and it was acceptable
results so yeah that's all the four
night I have for you today I have more
for night games but I think these were
the highlights just to show you how to
play this game and some of the little
tricks and what whatnots
so hopefully you will go and try it add
it to your repertoire and yeah
coordinate is cool you just have to know
what you're doing and be patient in it
and it gives your opponent all the
chances to make mistakes that's what I
really like about it and well thank you
for being with us for the full two hours
see you tomorrow for the chess960
[Music]
[Applause]
you